>> ELON MUSK PUSHED FOR
TRANSPARENCY TAINTED BY A TOP
LAWYER INSIDE TWITTER.
THE BILLIONAIRE FIRING THE
COMPANY'S LEGAL COUNCIL JAMES
BAKER FOR GOING BEHIND HIS BACK,
SECRETLY VETTING TWITTER FILES
BEFORE THEY'RE RELEASED, SLOWING
GETTING THE INFORMATION OUT TO
THE PUBLIC.
THE "NEW YORK POST" CALLS IT AN
INSIDE JOB.
IF YOU THOUGHT JIM BAKKER IS A
FAMILIAR NAME, HE USED TO WORK
FOR THE FBI AS GENERAL COUNSEL
UNDER JAMES COMEY, A CENTRAL
FIGURE INTO THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
REPUBLICANS ARE CALLING ON TOP
TWITTER EXECUTIVES TO TESTIFY
AND JIM JORDAN THINKS THAT WHAT
HAPPENED HELPED PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO GET ELECTED.
>> GIG GOVERNMENT, BIG MEDIA,
COLLUDING TO KEEP VALUABLE
INFORMATION FROM WE THE PEOPLE.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE THAT JOE
BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT AND WE
HAVE 41-YEAR HIGH INFLATION, A
BORDER THAT'S NO LONGER A
BORDER, RAMPANT CRIME, WHAT WE
SEE WITH THIS BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, AND AMERICA IS
NO LONGER TREATING AMERICANS
EQUALLY UNDER THE LAW.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE STILL STAYING
TIGHTLIPPED ABOUT THE
REVELATIONS.
>> DID ANYONE FROM THE BIDEN
TEAM COMMUNICATE TO TWITTER THAT
THIS MATERIAL WAS -- THAT THIS
REPORTING STEMMED FROM HACKED
MATERIALS.
>> I CAN'T SPEAK TO DECISIONS
MADE BY THE CAMPAIGN FROM HERE.
THAT IS NOT -- THAT'S A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
WHAT I CAN SAY MORE BROADLY IS,
OF COURSE, IT'S UP TO THESE
COMPANIES TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT THE CONTENT ON
THEIR PLATFORMS, TO ENSURE
CONTENT FOLLOWS THEIR OWN
STANDARDS AND POLICIES.
>> I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED,
JESSE, TO FIND OUT THAT JAMES
BAKER ACTUALLY STILL WORKED FOR
TWITTER, GIVEN THAT ELON MUSK
CLEANED A LOT OF THE HOUSE
BEFORE HE EVEN GOT STARTED.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE TO CLEAN HOUSE
WITH THE LAWYERS FIRST, BECAUSE
THEY KNOW A LOT.
>> HMM.
>> HE STUCK HIS NECK OUT THERE.
THEN HE GOT EXITED.
I LOVE THAT TERM.
HE GOT EXITED.
HE'S A FIXER.
HE DOESN'T HAVE LEGAL CHOPS.
HE WAS A BAD MAN FOR CROOKED AT
THE FBI.
THEN HE WENT TO THE OTHER SIDE
TO RUN INTERFERENCE FOR THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN AT TWITTER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A GOOD
LAWYER TO SUCCEED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU JUST HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO
POLITICAL FAVORS FOR PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW YOU ASCEND NOW.
YOU DO POLITICAL FAVORS AS A
LAWYER.
LAWYERS ARE DESTROYING THIS
COUNTRY.
EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK.
>> THEY'RE LAWYERS, BECAUSE
THEY'RE DOING LEGAL BUSINESS.
>> THEY'RE DOING POLITICAL
BUSINESS.
THEY'RE NOT DOING LEGAL
REMEMBER ANOTHER ONE, AVENATTI?
GREAT GUY.
AND ANOTHER LOOSENED THE
ELECTION LAWS FOR PAPER TO BLAST
OUT THERE.
WATCH YOUR HAN, GERALDO!
SUSSMAN.
ADAM SCHIFF.
EVERYWHERE YOU TURN, THERE'S A
STUPID DEMOCRATIC LAWYER TRYING
TO CUT YOUR KNEES OUT FROM UNDER
YOU.
>> HUNTER IS A LAWYER.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S WHY YOU CAN'T GET
ANYTHING DONE IN THIS COUNTRY.
ANYTIME YOU TRY TO BUILD
SOMETHING, FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT.
THEY'RE SUING TGIF FRIDAY'S
BECAUSE THERE'S CHEDDAR IN THE
MOZZARELLA STICK.
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY HATES THEM.
I HAVE A PROPOSAL.
ALL THE LAWYERS TAKE A PRACTICE
NEXT YEAR.
ONE YEAR.
ALL THE LAWYERS STOP THEIR
PRACTICE.
I GUARANTEE YOU, THIS COUNTRY
WOULD BE A PARADISE.
WHO MAKES MONEY IN CONFLICT?
THREE INDUSTRIES.
ARMS DEALERS, THE MEDIA, AND
LAWYERS.
THEY'RE CLEANING UP, BECAUSE
THEY BILL BY THE HOUR.
YOU BILL, YOU BILL, AND WE ALL
PAY, BECAUSE THE MORE CONFLICT
THERE IS THE MORE MONEY YOU
SHELL OUT.
ALL OUR LAWYERS LOSE.
THEY GET THEIR HOMES RAIDED,
IPHONEs, SEIZED, CONSTANTLY
YOU'RE ON THE BACK END.
>> WHAT DID YOU PUT IN YOUR
WATER TODAY?
>> NOT ENOUGH, GERALDO.
I THINK THE BIDEN FAMILY IS
BEING BLACKMAILED BY THE FBI.
WHEN THE FBI TEAMS UP WITH THE
LAWYERS, HELL ON EARTH.
>> CAN I BRING IT BACK TO EARTH?
THAT'S THE BEST JESSE WATTERS
IMPERSONATION I'VE EVER HEARD
FROM YOU, JESSE.
>> BESIDE KILL THE LAWYERS, JIM
JORDAN, WHAT HE SAID, THAT
BOTHERS ME ABOUT THIS WHOLE
TWITTER STORY.
THE IMPLICATION IS BECAUSE
TWITTER DIDN'T GO ALL OUT TO
BACK THE "NEW YORK POST," THE
ELECTION WAS THEREFORE FLAWED,
IT WAS FLAWED SO PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS JUSTIFIED IN SAYING THAT THE
ELECTION WAS, YOU KNOW, NOT
LEGITIMATE.
WE CAN TAKE WHATEVER MEANS
NECESSARY, SUSPEND THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY ABSURD TO THINK
THAT BECAUSE ONE MEDIA OUTLET,
TWITTER, DIDN'T BACK THE "NEW
YORK POST," THEREFORE THE
ELECTION IS FLAWED.
IT'S AN ASSUMPTION BUILT ON AN
ASSUMPTION BUILT ON AN
ASSUMPTION.
>> AND FACEBOOK, AND EVERYBODY.
AND THEY STOP CONVERSATIONS.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IMPERILLED
THE ELECTION.
10%, IT WOULD HAVE CHANGED THE
ELECTION.
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THERE'S STUDIES OUT THERE.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE, FORGET
ABOUT THIS GARBAGE WITH LAWYERS.
OKAY?
IF THERE WEREN'T ANY LAWYERS,
FIRST OF ALL, EVERY CRIMINAL IN
JAIL WOULD BE OUT OF JAIL RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD MAKE
YOU VERY HAPPY.
CHANCES ARE, IF THERE WEREN'T
ANY LAWYERS, IF YOU GOT HURT,
FIGHTING YOUR NEIGHBOR, YOU
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SUE YOUR
NEIGHBOR, ALL THAT STUFF.
>> THAT WOULDN'T BE A FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUIT.
THAT WOULD BE A RIGHTEOUS
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS GUY JAMES BAKER IS AS DEEP
STATE YOU CAN GET.
HE WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
RUSSIAN, TWITTER.
MIRANDA DIVINE HAVE TO HER
CREDIT SAID WHERE ARE THE EMAILS
THAT SHOWS FBI WAS COMMUNICATING
WITH TWITTER?
GOOD FOR YOU, MIRANDA.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE FOUND THE
EMAILS, WHERE THIS GUY JAMES
BAKER IS A PROFESSIONAL, MAKING
SURE THAT THE GOVERNMENT
INFLUENCES POLITICS AND POLICY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT AMAZES ME THAT SOMEONE THAT
IS A LAWYER IS SO ANTITHETICAL,
EVERYTHING HE THINKS IS
ANTI-FREE SPEECH.
WHO THINKS IN THOSE TERMS?
>> HE WAS JUST TRYING TO COVER
HIS ASS.
>> HE WASN'T COVERING HIS ASS.
>> THERE'S A JUSTIFICATION?
HE'S A CROOK.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED
FOR THE RUSSIAN DELUSION.
I AGREE WITH JESSE, HE WAS
FIRED.
YOU KNOW WHAT, HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PROSECUTED.
>> ARE YOU FINISHED?
>> I'M FINISHED.
>> LET'S TURN IT OVER TO YOU.
>> I WILL TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
I ENJOY WATCHING ON TWITTER HOW
THE REPORTERS GOING AFTER THE
REPORTERS FOR REPORTING THE
NEWS, AS IF THIS ISN'T NEWS.
SO WHAT THEY'RE DOING, THEY'RE
ACTING LIKE -- THEY'RE ACTING
LIKE THE MEDIA IS ON STRIKE, AND
WHEN YOU DO THIS STORY YOU'RE A
SCAB.
LIKE MATT TAIBBI IS A SCAB.
THE MEDIA GOES ON STRIKE TO NOT
COVER STORIES THAT WE LIKE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BORDER, AT
CRIME, IF YOU DO THOSE STORIES,
FOLLOW UP ON GENDER AFFIRMATION
SURGERIES, IF YOU DO THAT, THE
MEDIA WILL GO AFTER YOU,
BASICALLY TREAT YOU LIKE A SCAB.
AT THE CORRESPONDENTS DINNERS,
YOU GET THAT VIBE, EVEN THOUGH
WE CRUSH THEM IN THE RATINGS.
EVERYTHING THINKS YOU'RE CROSSED
THE PICKET LINE BECAUSE YOU DO
STORIES THAT MAKE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA UNCOMFORTABLE.
IF THAT'S A SC